hey i'm abby and this is a look at cloud
code's support
for custom samples enterprise
application development
poses unique challenges when juggling
multiple organization requirements and
dependencies
but what if you had a central starting
point to build applications configured
to your organization's needs
that's where cloud code's custom samples
feature can help out
custom samples can be starter
applications services
or infrastructure configurations that
are easy to share with your team
this gives your team a convenient secure
and discoverable starting point that
adheres to your organization's tech
stack
and compliance needs custom samples also
encourage best practices
at the beginning of your development
cycle and helps accelerate the time to
market for your team's ideas
to get started with custom samples your
organization first needs to define
applications and services in a versioned
git repo
that includes their techniques for
improving security compliance and other
app requirements
once configured this is called a custom
samples repo
developers with permission to the custom
samples rebo can then use cloud code to
connect to your organization's custom
samples repo
letting them easily import individual
apps and services that way your
developers spend more time
coding and less time configuring apps to
meet your organization's requirements
cloud code is available for a variety of
ides including jetbrains ides
vs code and cloud shell editor for this
video
i'll demo custom samples with visual
studio code
i already have cloud code installed from
the vs code extensions marketplace
so i'm ready to go let's say my
engineering manager
has set up a custom samples repo of
starter applications that my team
frequently uses
all these apps can easily be imported
into my ide's workspace
with cloud code to show what this flow
looks like
i'll use an example git repo the cloud
code team made
what makes this git repo a custom
samples repo
is the inclusion of one file dot cc
template
they look something like this every
samples folder
in your repo needs to be referenced in
this file
but let's go back to importing this
custom samples repo
first i'll grab the git url for the repo
switching back over to vs code i can go
through the same flow of creating a
sample app
but instead of selecting a kubernetes or
cloud run app
i'll instead click custom application
then i'll click import sample from repo
and paste in the url of the repo
all the samples from that repo are now
ready to be individually imported
into my workspace and now i'm ready to
code up a surface that has all the
dependencies i need
already included if you want to set up a
custom samples repo for your
organization
you can fork our example custom samples
repo and customize it to meet your
organization's needs
if you have any questions or feature
requests about cloud code
join our slack channel until next time
you